mes chers amis je ne suis pas venu
parler de françois hollande
encore moins d'anne hidalgo sujet sur
lequel il y aurait beaucoup à dire
je suis venu vous parler de nous de vous
d'où nous en étions nous nous en sommes
et où nous allons
c'est bien beau de se consacrer sur ses
adversaires c'est nécessaire mais ce
n'est pas suffisant il nous faut gagner
non pas parce qu'ils sont mauvais non
pas parce qu'ils conduisent la france
dans le désastre
non pas parce qu'à paris comme ailleurs
ils n'ont aucun projet digne de ce nom
il nous faut gagner parce que nous
porterons une force et un projet capable
d'arrêter la descente de notre pays vers
les abîmes
c'est de cela dont il s'agit de rien
d'autre il s'agit pas de choisir le
moins mauvais il s'agit de choisir
l'équipe qui aura la force car à
l'énergie qui aura la capacité d'éviter
rien moins que la disparition de notre
pays comme puissance mondiale de premier
plan
ce n'est pas rien la france la france
n'est pas une page blanche
nous sommes les héritiers d'une histoire
qui a fait de notre pays
l'un des seuls à travers le monde avoir
une vocation à l'universel sans doute
avec les états unis d'amérique
et oui les allemands les espagnols tant
d'autres à travers le monde ont
l'ambition légitime de la défense de
leurs intérêts la france toujours à
travers son histoire a une vocation à
défendre l'universel la france sont en
énerver beaucoup à travers le monde
la france est un pays qui a toujours
pensé une nation qui a toujours pensé
que son discours avait vocation à
rayonner au delà de ses propres
frontières
c'est ça la france et nous sommes les
héritiers de cette histoire nous pouvons
pas simplement porter un discours de nos
intérêts franco français nous devons
porter une vision cher pierre une vision
du monde où en étions-nous je suis très
heureux de parler devant les adhérents
de la fédération de paris ses adhérents
qui ont été pendant si longtemps
le coeur de notre famille politique et
qui pendant si longtemps porté la
victoire et qui au fil des divisions et
des règlements de compte internes
avaient fini par devenir le coeur de ce
qu'il ne fallait pas faire en termes de
division de haine interne de règlements
de comptes et de clans pour garder les
choses très simplement savoir comment
elle a fait pour gagner et savoir
comment on a fait pour perdre
il fut un temps on préférait même ne pas
faire de réunions dans l'espoir que nous
faisons pas de réunion il n'y aurait pas
d' étalage de division
cette époque appartient un temps
définitivement révolu pendant des années
j'ai connu notre famille politique où
l'ensemble de la presse est du reste de
la classe politique nous décrivait comme
une force exclusivement parisienne et
d'île de france
puis le temps a passé et d'étagé en
étage avec l'ascenseur qui descendait
nous sommes arrivés à nous replier sur
quelques bastions prétendu avant que les
passions prétendu ne tombent les uns
après les autres
pourquoi
le projet change de vision absence
d'union l'ambition la concurrence c'est
quand même pas moi qui vais les attaquer
mais l'ambition et la concurrence c'est
pas un droit c'est un devoir être
meilleur être meilleur qu'au mans pas
tout seul pour fédérer pour rassembler
pour additionner et non pas pour exclure
les règlements de comptes détestation
interne les divisions c'est fini et
quand je vous dis c'est fini c'est
vraiment fini
non pas que les hommes changer mais
dorénavant il y aura des procédures et
je ne suis pas décidé à accepter la
moindre attitude qui conduirait à
marquer des buts contre notre propre
camp la situation de la france est trop
grave
l' angoisse des français est trop
profonde
la colère qui monte est trop prégnante
pour tolérer cela la nomination de
frédéric que vous connaissez nos liens
de proximité participe de ce mouvement
ne s'agissait pas d' arbitrer entre
telle ou telle équipe telle ou telle
plante telle ou telle amitié il
s'agissait qu'ensemble on semble le
monde s'en va une signification ensemble
tous ensemble on a tous besoin les uns
des autres et quand je vois jean qui a
accompagné tellement pardon de le dire
ma jeunesse dans la vie politique qui
est présent je te dis gens on a aussi
besoin de gens qui comme toi représente
l'histoire de notre mouvement
ici nous ne sommes pas non plus une page
blanche
je le dis pour jean je le dis pour
philippe je le dis pour tous les autres
je le dis pour rachida jeudi pour chacun
d'entre vous amis très proches ou amis
moins proche
ensemble c'est trop difficile la vie
politique
en plus se permettre d'être séparés
ensuite il fallait remettre tout le
monde au travail
je croyais est dans nos valeurs le
travail était la valeur fondatrice
appliquons le nous à nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied travailler ça veut dire
quoi philippe pas simplement militer
réfléchir méditer y réfléchir débattre
chercher de nouvelles idées construire
de nouveaux projets analyser les défis
français pour essayer de porter une
vision originale et en même temps
conforme aux valeurs qui sont les nôtres
chose que doit être l'avenir de la
france nathalie par la juste dit du
grand paris j'ai voulu le grand paris et
je me retrouve avec un bébé que je ne
reconnais plus un espèce de mécano on
sait pas exactement comment le prendre
si ce n'est qu'il ya des présidents
partout des hochets donné à tout le
monde
c'est la seule organisation où vous me
voyez ni l'endroit ni l'envers où il n'y
a pas de gauche et pas de droite pas
d'eau et pas de bas c'est juste un truc
pour anesthésier tout le monde et être
sûrs qu'à l'arrivée on ne fait rien
voilà le projet ce qu'est devenu le
projet du grand paris
simplement un petit vision simplement un
peu de répartition nathalie pour qu'à
l'arrivée personne n'est pouvoir et
surtout personne ne décide pas ce que
vraiment la décision c'est pas bien
c'est pas tout à fait ma conception des
choses
je pense que le grand paris doit être le
grand paris des projets et non pas le
grand paris des structures je pense que
la façon de convaincre les franciliens
les parisiens de l'utilité du grand
paris 7 voir en quoi ce grand paris peut
changer leur vie quotidienne et non par
additionner des structures aux
structures alors que déjà les français
n'en peuvent plus de crouler sous les
structures qui justifie des impôts qui
explose un peu plus chaque jour et qui
empêcheront demain les maires les
présidents de départements président de
la région de faire quoi que ce soit
puisque la seule chose qui semble
intéresser monsieur hollande et ses amis
c'est d'empêcher que quelqu'un puisse
assumer ses responsabilités bah oui j'ai
j'ai une amie dans la salle je remercie
ça m'encourage
il nous faut réfléchir à ce que nous
voulons faire pourquoi parce que
naturellement l'alternance ne repose que
sur nos épaules
l'alternance régionales on a la chance
avec valérie pécresse d'avoir une très
remarquable candidate je dois dire qu
elle m'épate dans sa façon de faire
campagne à chaque instant et d'y penser
à chaque seconde
ça fait plaisir
savez moi j'aime quand les gens sont
motivés
j'en vois tellement qu'ils pensent que
c'est un droit d'être candidat par
parenthèse message personnel je souhaite
que tous ceux qui mettent autant
d'énergie pour être sur la liste des
régionales
une fois qu'ils y seront met autant pour
développer leurs idées pour se battre à
nos côtés j'y verrai je verrai je ne
mettrai pas de nom naturellement compte
tenu de la présence amicale de la presse
mais enfin faudrait pas trop poussé
c'est une plaisanterie pourquoi les
problèmes ont changé les défis ne sont
plus les mêmes
c'est fou l'accélération de l'histoire
et la profondeur des abymes dans
lesquels nous ont mis monsieur hollande
et ses amis
notre projet ne peut pas être de refaire
ce que nous avons fait parce que les
défis ont changé parce que la situation
est encore beaucoup plus grave
et parce qu'il va falloir être à la
hauteur de ces enjeux nathalie a porté
la réforme des statuts
nous avons voulu de la démocratie vous
avez été innombrables à voter sur les
questions d'immigration comme sur les
questions sociales cinquante mille
quarante mille vous continuerez à voter
c'est très important je vais prendre
deux ou trois exemples une affaire aussi
sensible que le droit du sol à
l'évidence le droit du sol fait partie
de l'identité de notre pays et en même
temps à l'évidence il faut le faire
évoluer
parce que le droit du sol ne vont pas de
remettre en cause mais nous voulons plus
de fraude sur le droit du sol
si nos avions débattu de cette question
uniquement à l'intérieur des instances
dirigeantes de notre formation nous
n'aurions eu droit alors qu'un échange
posture arbitrés par des éditorialistes
qui connaissent la réalité de très loin
nous avons débattu nous avons tranché
cette question en disant nous
maintiendrons le droit du sol
mais nous ne voulons pas l'automaticité
de l'obtention de la nationalité
française pour des gens qui aurait un
casier judiciaire pour des gens qui
seraient liés à une activité terroriste
ou même pour des gens qui seraient nés
en france de parents à l'époque en
situation illégale ce qui est un
détournement ni plus ni moins que du
droit du sol
nous avons débattu
chacun dit s'il était d'accord s'ils
étaient moins d'accord à l'arrivée il ya
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup frappé et
beaucoup intéressé
c'était des propositions fortes qui
n'ont fait l'objet en vérité d'aucune
polémique
personne n'a dit personne que les
républicains n'avaient pas en matière
migratoire désormais des idées nouvelles
des idées fortes adaptée à la gravité de
la situation
pourquoi parce qu'on en a débattu et
parce que vous avez tranché sur la
question des réfugiés politiques
question très sensible
pourquoi est-ce une question sensible
parce que si la france n'est plus le
pays qui accueille celui qui est
persécuté la france perd une partie de
son identité mais en même temps si on
confond le réfugié politique elle
réfugiés de guerre alors on fait
disparaître le réfugié politique
derrière le réfugié de guerre car il ya
une grande différence entre eux c'est
que le réfugié de guerre a vocation à
rentrer dans son pays une voix que la
guerre est terminée dans son pays
nous avons pu évoquer ces questions nous
avons pu en débattre sont que cela pose
la moindre polémique ou la moins de
fracture entre nous l'europe
il ya dans notre famille politique des
gens dont je suis qui croient dans
l'europe
je n'abandonnerai jamais mon combat
européen il y en a dans notre famille
politique qui sont plus souverainiste
comme l'ont dit mais nous avons pu
trouver un point d'équilibré européen ou
souverainiste sur la nécessité non pas
de réformes et l'europe mais de la
refonder parce que l'europe d'hier six
décennies avec six pays n'a plus rien à
voir avec le projet politique
d'aujourd'hui ou 19 pays ont une monnaie
unique et aux 28 se trouvent rassemblés
dans une union européenne qui ne peut
plus continuer à fonctionner avec les
règles à 6 chaque fois chaque soir on a
pu rassembler les points de vue et
aujourd'hui je suis heureux de pouvoir
le dire il n'y a plus une personne qui
puisse penser dans notre famille
politique que schengen puisse continuer
comme cela
schengen c'est fini
schengen doit être refondu schengen doit
être imaginé
nous allons continuer comme nous l'avons
fait pour le code du travail on a un
petit peu élargi les choses là encore en
france on adore parler du dialogue
social n'y a plus on en parle moins on
le fait il n'est pas social et c'est pas
du dialogue
ça se passe avec des formations
syndicales excusez moi qui ne démontre
en aucun cas leur représentativité et
qui lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle se sont comportés comme
des sous partis politiques appelant
comme un seul homme à voter pour
françois hollande ce qui n'était pas
leur rôle
le spectacle qui a été donné dans cette
grande entreprise nationale qu'air
france ce spectacle est indigne de la
république française 2 4 apeurée à la
chemise déchirée au bord du lynchage
dans la france de 2015 cela porte un nom
c'est la chienlit et si ça plaît pas à
monsieur valls
alors qu'ils m'écoutent bien c'est la
chienlit
imaginez quand même que dans une
entreprise donc le premier actionnaire
est en vérité l'état une entreprise
souvient le drapeau avec les trois
couleurs sur le fuselage des avions une
entreprise qui porte le nom de notre
pays
air france la france et le monde entier
qui voit qu'à air france en 2015
deux cadres qui n'ont fait que leur
devoir en expliquant ce que devait être
le projet de redressement de la
compagnie se trouve lynché par une bande
de nervis qui sont la honte de la
compagnie voilà la réalité des choses
nous ne voulons pas de ce spectacle en
transe le cher frédéric mieux
croyez vous que la sanction tomba
d'abord sur les agresseurs non on
apprend benoîtement qu'après la visite
du premier ministre
c'est le directeur des relations
humaines qui est donc licencié et
remplacé par le collaborateur de valls
lui-même va seyant démontrer à satiété
sa grande compétence à gérer les
problèmes de notre pays
ça rassure pour air france marquez
aurait pu avoir pire et a pu choisir un
collaborateur de françois hollande
on l'a échappé belle mais rendez vous
compte du signal qui est envoyé dans
toutes les entreprises de france
c'est donc la violence qui paye c'est
donc le délitement de l'état qui paye un
homme fait son travail
un comité d'entreprise censé organiser
le dialogue social est investi par 1000
ou 1500 personnes déchaînées et la
conclusion il y aura peut-être une
enquête sur les agresseurs mais rate
tout de suite une sanction sur celui qui
a essayé de porter un projet de
redressement
c'est inacceptable et les républicains
que nous sommes nous ne pouvons pas
l'accepter
nous voulons changer complètement les
règles du jeu syndical
d'abord nous ne voulons plus que dans
aucune entreprise de france
il y est un délégué syndical qui soit
nommé nous voulons qu'il soit et le élus
par les salariés dans l'entreprise par
coeur
même si ça ne plaît pas à l'eba bhl
secrétaire général de la cgt dont j'ai
complètement oublié le nom
je souhaite que les élections dans les
entreprises soit libre dès le premier
tour et qu'il soit mis fin au monopole
de présentation des candidats au premier
tour d'une élection professionnelle dans
l'entreprise
il n'y a aucune raison qu'il n'y ait
qu'un seul monopole dans notre pays
le monopole de syndicats qui veulent
détruire alors que nous nous voulons
bâtir
et que dire
et que dire de ces grands mots dont on
s'enivre et parmi ceux-ci le paritarisme
le paritarisme
c'est devenu le parent le paravent de
l'immobilisme qui gère l'assurance
maladie qui ici capable de me le dire
quel est le nom de la personne qui gère
les assedic qui ici est capable de me le
dire personne ça change tous les ans et
toute manière ça me change rien puisque
celui qui dirige a comme caractéristique
de ne pas vouloir diriger dans le même
temps les assedic s'en vont vers un
déficit de 35 milliards d'euros c'est à
dire l'équivalent d'une année de
cotisation prélevée sur les entreprises
je le dis comme je le pense
c'est la décision prise en prise
ensemble nous reviendrons sur
paritarisme que l'état prenne ses
responsabilités le remettrons de l'ordre
dans les comptes
les comptes une fois rétablie nous le
rendrons aux partenaires sociaux
mais il ya un travail à faire et je
travaille on va le faire il faut prévoir
la dégressivité des allocations chômage
pour que celui qui est au chômage ne
puisse pas refuser un emploi ou une
formation qu'on lui propose il le doit à
la société et le doit notamment à ceux
qui par leurs impôts financent les
allocations qui lui sont octroyés
et vous voyez se dessiner petit à petit
un projet politique des républicains
forts adaptée à la situation
seule de nature à éviter quoi mais
évitez mes chers amis le drame que
serait l'élection dans nos régions ou
dans notre pays ne représentant d'une
formation politique le front national
avec qui je veux rappeler que nous
n'avons rien n'avoir rien du tout et ça
m'amène pour terminer mon propos à vous
parler politique au plus profond de la
politique comme si vous êtes parce que
vous êtes des responsables politiques
la seule alternative au front national
c'est nous nous préoccuper patron de
françois hollande sont finies ya plus
une personne qui peut penser une seule
que c'est rattrapable
il fut un temps où santini disait qu'à
force de chuter dans les sondages
j'avais fini par trouver du pétrole mais
lui françois hollande
il est au niveau du gaz de schiste
beaucoup plus bas
le problème c'est qu'il faut pas que nos
compatriotes passe du mensonge quotidien
je le dis comme je le pense à ce que
représenterait la folie du choix dans
l'inconnu du saut dans l'inconnu de gens
qui portent des idées qui ont applaudi
si prince lorsqu'il est arrivé en grèce
qui ont un programme économique qui rien
d'autre que celui de mélenchon qui n'ont
comme seule description de la france on
avait honte quand on entendait marine le
pen parlé à françois hollande
et quels que soient les reproches que
j'ai à faire à françois hollande je ne
pense pas qu'on combatte utilement pour
la france en ayant cette attitude dit
avec monsieur hollande ni avec son
propre père ces gens parlent de la
famille et comment vivent ils leur vie
familiale
cette personne qui est d'une telle
violence madame le pen à l'endroit de
son père dans lequel était bien contente
de récupérer l'héritage
elle ne se bouge c'est pas le nez
manable peine lorsqu'il s'agissait de
ramasser la petite entreprise familiale
madame le pen ça l'a pas gênée dans
l'entre-temps le détail et toutes les
folies de son père
madame le pen s est rendu compte ya un
mois que son père était infréquentable
nous ça fait qu en tant qu on le sait
que son père est infréquentable
comprenez moi bien je ne suis pas du
genre à m'incliner devant la pensée
unique
franchement je n'ai pas changé et je ne
suis pas du genre non plus à chercher
des compliments d'un monde médiatique
dont je connais parfaitement les règles
mais je ne veux pas je n'accepterai
jamais que les républicains nous sommes
nous tombions dans la caricature
parce que la caricature fait et rend
service à monsieur hollande et à madame
le pen nous avons des convictions si
fortes que nous n'avons pas besoin
d'aller dans la caricature
nous avons des convictions ses fortes
que nous voulons les défendre devant
tous les français quelles que vous soyez
je ne parle pas un plan je ne parle pas
une secte
je ne parle pas une équipe de supporters
je parle à la france à la france dans sa
diversité à la france dans sa générosité
à la france dans son histoire et vous
êtes les bienvenus chez les républicains
si vous aimez la france si vous croyez
en la france si vous parler le français
si vous aimez la culture française si
vous défendez le mode de vie concept
vous êtes les bienvenus quel que soit
votre couleur de peau quelles que soient
nos origines
quel que soit votre religion quelle que
soit
le vote n'ont jamais neves pas
j'explique quel que soit le vote qui fut
le vôtre lors des dernières élections
j'ai commencé mon propos en vous disant
on aura besoin de tout le monde pour
développer les républicains mon
raisonnement est le même pour la france
on a besoin de tous les français de
bonne volonté on a besoin de tout cela
quel que soit leur âge je les dis quelle
que soit leur région
je le pense quel que soit leur choix
politiques d'hier ça m'est égal ce qui
compte c est ce qu'ils sont comme nous
conscients de la gravité de la situation
du pays
et s'ils sont comme nous conscients
qu'il faut des idées nouvelles pour
redresser le pays
c'est de cela dont on a besoin de cela
et seulement de cela enfin le débat et
l'autorité
christian j'ai l'impression de me
trouver dans le grand amphi de sciences
po
ce ne sont pas des preuves des problèmes
théoriques d'abord il me semble curieux
comme pour le travail que les
républicains défendent la valeur du
travail et plaide pour moins de travail
il me semblerait curieux semblerait
conditionnel que les républicains ne
défendent pas la valeur de l'autorité
l'autorité la crise et nommé nal de
l'autorité est au coeur de la
problématique de l'identité française
il n'y a plus d'autorité plus d'autorité
de l'état
puis l'autorité à l'école où je reste
incontestablement attachés à des
symboles quand le maître rentrer dans la
classe les enfants se lèvent
quel que soit leur âge en signe de
respect quand on entre dans une pièce et
qu'une personne plus âgée que vous n'a
pas un siège on se relève pour lui
laisser la place non je sais c'est très
simple enfin ça peut servir
je pense que lorsqu'on a été condamné à
une peine de prison et qu'on est
dangereux on n'a pas vocation à voir une
permission de sortie
vous avez vu qu'on un nouvel humoriste
dans la vie politique française
non madame taubira qui va résoudre le
problème des permissions de sortie pour
les détenus dangereux
elle a tout compris on va leur mettre
une escorte de policiers pour que
naturellement ces braves gens ne fassent
pas de mauvaises rencontres durant leur
permission de sortie c'est exactement ce
qu'on voulait c'est vraiment ce que
souhaitaient les français mais mes chers
amis le débat la liberté les idées que
vous portez les votes que vous
manifesterez le choix des candidats ou
des candidates pour les régionales comme
pour les présidentielles
tout ça c'est formidable mais je ne
connais pas une entité humaine qui
puisse fonctionner sans une autorité
minima sans quelqu'un qui au final doit
porter le poids de la décision
parce que quand on prend pas de décision
on a tous les inconvénients de l'absence
de décision et aucun des avantages de la
prise de décision notre mouvement l'a
connu cette situation chacun se pensait
chef à la place du chef ou chacun
exigeait que sa ligne prévalent sur
celles des autres où chacun affirmait
ses prétentions et ses ambitions
cette période est terminée il ya un
président de la famille qui a été élu et
qui est là pour faire le travail plus
président
vous savez quelle est la spécificité du
président de la famille tous les autres
peuvent parler
le président de la famille doit décider
et je déciderai à chaque fois que je
pense que l'intérêt général de notre
famille politique et de notre pays est
en cause nous aurons un projet fort
jamais un projet qui dépassera ou
débordera les lignes des républicains
parce que débordés les lignes des
républicains c'est faire preuve de
faiblesse et moi je souhaite qu'on fasse
preuve de force
voilà petit à petit ce que nous allons
faire
j'ai voir est vraiment sonné derniers
mots parfois il ya un peu d'inquiétude
sur les primaires qu'est ce que ça va
donner
n'ayez aucune inquiétude parce que les
forces centripètes ont leurs
conséquences mais les forces centrifuges
non si je m'aperçois que les choses
progressent maintenant le tronçon commun
du projet politique des républicains
plus personne ne le conteste
manquerait plus que ça maintenant le
calendrier les régionales d'abord les
présidentielles ensuite toute personne
chacun accepte il ya dix sept têtes de
liste c'est fait il ya un accord
politique avec les centristes c'est fait
eh bien on va continuer tranquillement
comme cela monsieur yves et oui moi je
vais vous dire une chose
l'accord avec les centristes je
revendique c'est moi qui l'ait voulu et
chez moi qu'il défendrait pourquoi parce
que dans la même salle mes chers amis si
tout l'été dans la presse on avait vu
bagarre entre la droite républicaine et
le centre vous sauriez là en train de me
dire vous n'êtes pas devenu fou vous
pouvez pas vous arrangez vous pouvez pas
vous additionnez vous n'avez pas vu ses
papiers laissant la division aux autres
et continuons en ordre continuons avec
un calendrier avec une règle
respectons ce calendrier et c'est
presque tous ensemble je vous assure on
apportera les réponses qu'attendent la
france un an et demi deux mois pour
gagner les régionales un an pour
préparer les primaires un an et demi
pour la présidentielle c'est très peu et
c'est beaucoup mais si vous saviez à
quel point leur a besoin de vous de
votre soutien de votre participation de
votre ep de votre engagement de votre
volonté de votre détermination
merci philippe merci frédéric merci à
notre tête de liste régionale pour moi
être ici avec vous au fond ça fait un
week-end qui commence bien
pour arriver au combat
aulas
à
non